okay it's 2762 i have played with him
before
so let's go it's okay time sikorsky
stream
attack is the best defense
as they say
i wonder okay let's let's just castle
and then when you think
yeah i was a little bit concerned about
this move let's take you the pawn so if
he takes it if he plays e5
okay i take and then i play four
or actually not
okay let's go d4 of course you shouldn't
play like this yeah i don't do this at
home
but you know i'm lately in mood to play
some
some sort of rubbish openings
not as bad after all not that bad
my thoughts on nakamura bought his drama
but what's the drama i'm a little bit
uh not in the whole
story so uh could you please guys
enlighten me what's going on
that's a bad move but
ah doesn't matter
i'm here to suffer
i'm just here to suffer
that's for sure
why do i play like this here i mean
i could surely play in a normal way
okay take
but uh you know my position is so
disgusting
like it would it wasn't a sukhoi it was
some bad opening
is surely far better than this
okay now we gotta think not to resign in
a few moves
just to prolong our suffering
they unfollowed hikaru on twitter oh
this is this is harsh
like this is uh there you know like the
red card in football
amazing and follow someone on twitter
it's
i'm just i'm just speechless guys
whoa unfollowed i mean okay
why do we guys even care about it
why didn't he take the pawn i don't know
i don't know okay now at least my knight
goes to g3 to f5 now i get a plan
ah all right let's move
let's move
what do i do so he can go knight h5
indeed
uh yep so should i take on h6
immediately or not
okay let's try let us try
this risky move very risky
very risky i play okay if someone is
hanging
oh that's that's brave
he forces me into hurricane game
basically
maybe i can
maybe i can go here and then play rook
g1 i don't want four who can get my
rooks are
not saved if it's not better at all
so i go this
i surely take and give a check
and what do i do now no idea frankly
speaking
hmm go f4
so this is a good square no no no no no
no no no no no
this this doesn't work my friend
okay thank you